[Music]
many students myself included are
worried about their test scores what
advice to have them this is probably the
most frequently asked question that I
get is what about my GMAT score what
about my GRE or we accept students with
a wide range of test scores and it is
just one data point and I truly mean
that so my best advice is well we look
at the tests and they are important to
ensure that you're gonna be able to
thrive quantitatively and verbally in
the program so my best advice is we look
at it you should take spend some time
preparing what I hope for every
applicant is when they submit that score
and I know it's stressful that you feel
it's at least a decent reflection of
what your capabilities are so that's
where the preparation comes in that
being said though I know for many
students test taking is not their Forte
so again if there's a score honestly in
an application where it's far from maybe
what our median might be and we we do
admit people in the 500 to 600 in the
700s but if I see this may not be the
strongest point of their application
that's when I'm diving into the
transcript and seeing again how do they
learn maybe tests just aren't their
thing